e
open the uh October meeting of the
Health and Human Services oversight
committee and representative Murphy are
you acting clerk today did I hear no I
think represent Merchant representative
merchand all right no you're going we
didn't do that in the last day that
somebody president and that was one of
the rules that we passed two years ago I
think it was I'm just going to Slither
way back in my seat here in case anybody
me
to okay have you decided between the two
of you I
have okay thank you Senator uh
representative uh soon to me lay person
um yeah okay would the acting
here representative Edwards here
representative King not here
representative Merchant here
representative McDonald excused he's at
a county meeting
okay representative sent in sent in his
um uh request to be absent Senator Rosen
here presid and representative Murphy is
here in the um role as member
or need me as a member sure member yeah
Senator avard is doing flood remediation
quinsey uh we have before us the minutes
of the last meeting and
uh Mr chair yes did we establish a Corum
you do we have a
motion representative Edwards
moves
second okay I'll second second thank you
just I wasn't
here that's good I'll second the minutes
um I just did all in favor I opposed
thank
you
briefly the uh one one of the items in
the minutes uh was um in reference to
the Medicaid for schools program and
that was uh it's listed under
representative Merchant but I I I think
I raised it um it's no big deal in the
minutes but I just want to make sure
since it's says that the will the the
department will be here in October or
November to talk about the Medicaid for
schools program I just want to make sure
that we're working on November so
because it's it's a critical issue and
update okay I see a nodding and that's
really to the chair just to acknowledge
that okay thank you attorney Edwards and
I have discussed this yeah we'll make
sure
pleas did we approve the minutes I think
so yes we did all right uh next agenda
item emerging Medical Technology study
committee annual report representative
Jess Edwards for five minutes it's not
going to take five minutes I I spoke to
it a little bit last uh session uh what
what we ended up doing is um is having
the inaugural meeting kind of late in
the uh in September sometimes in
September and um since it was the first
meeting what we were able to do is I I I
was elected uh as the chair of that
committee uh and I got enough guidance
from the committee so that we could put
together an annual report the annual
report didn't have much uh to say um
because uh we just had the one meeting
but what we did agreed to doing is to
have another um is that the the
committee probably can deliver some
value we're going to give it a try we
think our first meeting of the next term
is going to be sometime in February so
that after the election we can get and
speakership and stuff we can get uh
folks nominated to the committee um i'
I've beg begun to reach out to various
speakers um I have uh I've talked to um
at least two that could come in and give
us sort of an educational overview of
what emerging medical technology is is
out there and how it might impact the
healthcare system and um and I intend
after the election depending on the
results to write a letter to um the the
the the the military agency that handles
Advanced Medical Technology emerging
medical technology to see if we can
establish some kind of a relationship
with them so uh the hope of all of this
is is that if nothing else we gain some
more subject matter expertise within the
legislature so that we understand the
potential of emerging medical technology
and what the implications are for uh
clinical trials and use here in the
state um and whether or not we need
enabling legislation to be in a position
to consider it intelligently before it's
too late in the process um and um and
and and that's sort of the this the hope
uh coincidentally uh Representative
Keith Ammon is trying to get a caucus
together to talk about emerging
technology in general without it having
the medical stove pipe to it and so I've
told them I'd be interested in
participating in that caucus um and uh
there may be a good deal of correlation
between them so so that's uh that's
that's my report I um we'll we we'll see
who's going to be involved
come um post election um so that's all
if there are any questions I'll answer
them any
questions all right thank you seeing
none thank
you DHHS Commissioners update Ellen Leo
CEO New Hampshire hospital to make this
presentation
good morning chairman and committee
members thank you for allowing me to
make the presentation on behalf of the
commissioner's update this morning my
name is Ellen Le Point and I am the CEO
at New Hampshire hospital and I am going
to be sharing with you today you you
have a slide deck um they it looks like
two slides per page you got it um and
I'll be reviewing this presentation with
you it's in regards to our high security
unit at New Hampshire hospital and I
want to create some clarity right from
the beginning because I'm using a phrase
um high security as opposed to the
phrase forensic and I'd like to talk a
little bit more about why that is later
on in the presentation but just wanted
to make sure that everyone knew I was
talking about the construction project
that's currently occurring at New
Hampshire
hospital uh the the the size of of the
unit is uh 24 bits and that is in
parallel to the size of our existing
units the majority of our existing units
at New Hampshire hospital so it's really
an additional unit that's going to be
added to the hospital there is some
other components of this particular unit
given the population that it will serve
that does make it larger than our
current units um there are some specific
recreational areas for the patient
population that it will be
serving and again just to create Clarity
that this will be attached to New
Hampshire hospital it's not going to be
on the side of the hospital it will be
attached to our existing structure as
well as the intent to have it be
accredited through the Joint Commission
who the hospital is accredited with
currently and will not require a
separate accreditation in order to serve
this
population um so I'll go to the first
slide which is the agenda and we'll be
talking briefly just to keep you all
apprized that we have had several
community outreach sessions to keep the
community informed of the progress today
we'll also be discussing how those
Outreach sessions can be accessed online
should you choose to view them and we'll
be talking about briefly about the
design of the unit the construction
timeline why we're building this unit
the patient population it will serve
some brief construction updates and also
some architectural renderings and this
slide that you see in front of you that
has the agenda on it also has a picture
of the rendering um that was provided to
us by the
architect so the next slide is in
regards to the community outreach
sessions we've had six community
outreach sessions so far being held from
October of
2021 through August 29th was our most
recent of 2024 to inform the public
those sessions have been well attended
they were more highly attended
in um the initial stages of the Outreach
to the community our most recent session
had about a dozen participants yet still
some very informative questions and
ability to continue to create clarity
about the project so we've been pleased
with those sessions so
far according to our pre-established
timeline we do have at least one
additional community outreach session
that's scheduled for this early summer
of next year 2025 however it's highly
likely that we will schedule additional
sessions as
well and you can see on there of course
the DHHS website if you wanted to view
or listen to any of the community
outreach sessions that have occurred so
far they all were
recorded and also include um copies of
the slide decks in
PDF uh next slide again just a little
bit more clarity as to where those
sessions can be found and we have
continuously provided this contacted
information it's the New Hampshire
Hospital's admin support mailbox so that
individuals who are viewing these
sessions or should happen to view them
after they occurred would still be able
to outreach to us should they have any
questions and that has occurred I have
had folks reach out and we've been able
to create clarity as we've
progressed next slide you'll see the
construction time the design and
construction timeline so of course
across the top you'll see the years that
we've been uh
pretty kneed deep in this work although
many years prior to uh get us to this
point and the uh next swim Lane is the
quarters or corresponding quarters or
months of those years so you can see we
are moving to the far right hand side of
the current timeline in quarter 3 of
2024 that yellow circle indicates the
August Outreach session that just
occurred and you can see below that we
are kneed deep in our construction
currently I'm sure that this timeline
will continue to get updated as time
progresses but it's our current our most
currently sure yeah we can take
questions during the representative
Edwards thank you so looking at the
Timeline it implies that uh you'll be
open for business at the end of Q2 of
2025 or or what is the projected
completion date the projected completion
date at this point we are still
approximately two years away from being
able to occupy the facility I anticipate
that formal construction will be
completed by the end of
2026 based on the current timeline as
provided by the construction company
however that doesn't necessarily
immediately equate to occupancy because
there are permit processes that we have
to go through Fire Marshall checks it
infrastructure that we need to make sure
is present all of those internal
components that need to be in place
prior to occupancy right okay so so that
would be good for a future update to
know what our what we're expecting right
absolutely and and then the may I and
and so the two big questions typically
on something like this is uh are we on
time and are we on budget and I I I I
suspect we're not on time because of uh
some of the groundwater issues that we
ran into um that probably didn't help
the budget either though so so what how
are we from a budget perspective and
where's the money coming from the
additional money thankfully from a
budget perspective we are aligned still
um I haven't heard otherwise from the
construction team or the architect or
the Department of Public Works we did
take longer than originally anticipated
to be able to perform the uh
foundational work that has currently
occurred however I'm under the
impression that all of that timeline was
built in to our most recent uh budget
allocation for the work of course as
they continue to progress and continue
to dig um that may change but in it in
its current state I'm not we're not
concerned about the budget currently all
right thank you and thank you Mr
chair Senator Rosenwald thank you thank
you Mr chair good morning I just want to
confirm that when this is open the
patients who are currently at the spu
will be
moved thank you for the question Senator
Rosen Wald so that actually goes to the
point a bit that I'll um elaborate on a
little bit further in the presentation
but you're accurate the patient
population that we aim to serve
immediately upon opening of the facility
will be the Civil committed individuals
you uh um okay if the current population
at sbu is going here who's going to
Hamstead
this correct got it thank
you so speaking of the patient
population um is our next slide and
there are primarily three patient
populations who are going to be
considered for this unit and those are
patients who have not committed an
unlawful act but because of their mental
illness are too dangerous to be treated
at a conventional Psychiatric Hospital
those are the primary members who will
be transitioning from the spu who are
essentially civy committed currently to
that location but are New Hampshire
hospital patients so they'll be
returning to us as I understand in the
current state there are approximately 22
of those individuals currently at spu
and just a reminder that this unit will
have an occupancy of 24
other patient populations are patients
who are involved in the criminal justice
system and suffering from a serious
mental illness and are actively
dangerous to themselves or
others in the third patient population
are patients who are accused of an
unlawful act but cannot go to trial
because of their illness and are acutely
dangerous to themselves or others or
incompetent to stand trial so I wanted
to take a moment here may I jump in at
that point please House built 1020
established a committee to look at
restoration to competency I was elected
chairman of that we finished our first
year initial report because the bill
takes us into
2025 where looking at various ways where
restoration to competency can actually
be attempted intentionally because right
now if it happens it because it happens
um we
expressed Wonder as to to what degree
could this Center assist in restoration
of Competency we left it open because we
wanted to have a more of a conversation
which we hadn't had so I said then let's
not presume it but that's a conversation
we would like to have uh do you have any
thoughts going forward about that sure
and thank you for the question
representative um I think
that it might pose challenges to
consider that this unit would have the
ability to restore competency and that's
for a couple of reasons one is that the
primary focus of both the department and
New Hampshire hospital is to keep the
patient in the center of our decision-
making and our treatment in terms of
Competency restoration the client in
those circumstances is primarily the
court system so it's not that that New
Hampshire hospital uh wouldn't be able
to treat these individuals and
competency may be able to be achieved
through that treatment however if you
make the distinction that uh competency
restoration belongs to New Hampshire
hospital or to the department it's not
quite in alignment with the Department's
mission in terms of serving the patient
function senator rosenal
thank you Mr chairman of the
22 current patients at the
spu are any of them from the county
jails yes I don't know the number off
hand but yes that would be accurate okay
thank
you and let me follow up on mine um
while I was writing down I thank you for
that give me time to write it down
um where it exists
restoration of competence he an orphan
yeah and we are examining other states
to see who would be a good adoptive
parent to this in Haller part but uh
perhaps we could have a chat at some
point after the first of the year yeah
I'd be happy too thank you Mr chair
representative we had a question I'm
just curious this phrase means because I
don't I don't know what this restoration
mhm so for the chair are we talking
about
restoring people who are in uh group
three so people accused of an unlawful
act but could not go to trial because of
their illness because of their lack of
Competency is that yes they're not able
consciously intentionally to assist in
their own defense right and so I just
wanted to express my
concern that going
forward my my concern about the
conflation of
treatment and I think I'm speaking
mostly about the same thing you are but
there's there's a complete difference
between treatment as a therapeutic thing
and treatment for the purpose of
rendering somebody liable to punishment
and I think that if we are trying to
blend them in the same blender we're
going down a slippery slope that I would
be very sorry to see us go down and I
also think that um you know there are
things that lead to lack of Competency
that can be treated I mean the obvious
one I think of is malnutrition or an
underlying untreated medical condition
but beyond
that um the reasons for incompetence are
so Myriad that um having that as a
treatment goal seems to me to be very
very problematical in many senses and I
know you're already studying that I just
wanted to get that on the record in this
hearing uh because I think that's
probably a rabbit hole we don't want to
go down right now no we have other
things to do but for the purposes of our
committee we have examined that and the
uh contos of is it ethical even to treat
somebody so they can stand trial on the
other hand contos that is what about
Justice for the individuals what about
people who um are let out but have not
faced uh a judge we're aware of all of
that which is why I'm grateful we have
another whole year to play with that
thank you thank you thank you okay keep
going oh sorry representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair I'm trying to do
understand the difference between
treatment versus housing um and what I'm
not sure of yet is that if they're
coming into the facility for
treatment how is that different because
the length of state has a lot to do with
occupancy as far as capacity M so if
they're going to be there for just the
treatment for a relatively short period
of time until either they go to trial go
on to some of facility if it becomes
more of a housing issue and they're
there for a
longterm what happens s to the capacity
the ability to take on more
incoming U patients if you will my
concern is the capacity issue between
coming in and staying there sure thank
you for the question but just to create
Clarity are you speaking specifically
about this unit or New Hampshire
hospital as a whole this particular unit
is that if they stay there for too long
of a period of time and they don't move
on then at that point in time we have a
log Jam agreed thank you for the
question it's definitely uh an important
one and something that should be
considered because although I'm not a
clinician I do understand that being
able to effectively treat this
population of individuals will take a
longer length of time than the the let's
say standard uh for for lack of a better
phrase patient that we treat currently
in New Hampshire Hospital's existing
state so I I do think that um although
discharge planning is the primary goal
for all of our patients it will take
some additional time to treat this
patient population and we have to be
mindful of that given that it is only a
24 bed
unit representative Weber yeah follow up
first let let oh okay thank you thank
you
Mr given the fact that there is a
capacity that we have to stay within
because it's only 24
beds what happens if we don't have the
ability to take in more patients what
where do they go how does the system
going to handle that issue if there's a
bottleneck there and then all of a
sudden we have situation where back to
holding up other components because if
you think about at least I'm thinking
about it through there's different
grades of what you have to deal with
some can go to the hospital some have to
go to the security Center um high
capacity or high security so what's the
plan if we have a bottleneck there how
do we deal with it again thank you I
think it's a great question and it is
questions that we've been asking
ourselves in trying to collaborate with
uh the department of corrections to come
up with the best solution I will say
though that one of the things about this
model that we hope to be very beneficial
in that regard is the fact that it is
attached to New Hampshire hospital and
if in a point in time any of the 24
individuals residing in the high
security space are stabilized enough
that they can transition into New
Hampshire Hospital's current civil
locations or units that we would have
the flexibility to do so and therefore
open up beds in the high security
space representative Weber and I guess
my my question was the same from the
opposite point of view we have a
population approximately the same size
right now at the
spu and presumably that is subject to
the same kinds of considerations and
bottlenecks what we're doing is
transferring a present population from
one locality to another
locality and yes all of those issues are
the same but they are the same issues
that we're currently dealing with in a
far less appropriate environment and so
let us all my comment would be let us
all hope that uh transferring to a more
therapeutically appropriate environment
might help actually releas some of that
bottleneck but understanding that these
are particularly difficult persons to
treat correct thank you for that um and
and I would completely agree although
the this plan won't necessarily add a
tremendous amount of relief to capacity
in the overall system it is
transitioning individuals to a more
therapeutic environment and although the
spu works very hard and has some
wonderful people um employed there think
and I've had the opportunity to visit
and collaborate with them especially in
the more recent months as we plan for
this unit um it's not a healthcare
environment so this is transitioning the
population to a more therapeutic
environment and as representative Weber
indicated in hopes that it will
perpetuate their ability to heal and
become more stabilized therefore helping
throughput um so if I could just pause
for a second although it's not on the
slide I did think that this was a good
opportunity to create a little bit more
clarity around the term forensic so I
just wanted to make sure folks
understood that forens the term forensic
is a bit of a misnomer in terms of the
plan that I just described for this unit
there was a previous iteration of the
plan that included upwards of 60 beds
for this build we were able to receive
funding to have 24 bits so the intention
of this unit really is going to be
transitioning those 22 patients from spu
who are essentially civil committed in
Corrections into a healthcare
environment those individuals may or may
not have forensic
involvement and currently in New
Hampshire Hospital's current state we
treat forensic patients all the time
throughout the hospital um so using the
term forensic for this unit isn't
necessarily the most accurate
description of the individuals who will
okay yes so yeah representative Edwards
thank you Mr chair so so that just gets
my mind wandering between potential
disconnect between the enabling law at
60 beds for forensic hospital and what
we're actually going to do and how we're
making sure that we're complying with
the law or we're changing the law is and
maybe you're not the right one to ask
but I i' I'd like to know if we need to
do anything to tweak the law so that
we're not breaking the law in this
transition thank you for asking that
question and I'm happy to take that back
we have been looking at that especially
as I said in the more recent months
because we've sort of gotten to this
point in our operational planning as we
collaborate with the Department of
Corrections and DHHS in the population
that will initially serving that it does
uh it's it's it's not the full 60 right
it's 24 and in the priority are the
individuals who are civil committed who
may or may not be forensic individuals
so um there is work happening behind the
scenes to make sure that all of that is
aligned and well intended in terms of um
law followup and just to make it clear I
I I I'm just anticipating
somebody someday wanting to sue us and I
would just like us to be uh
operationally in compliance with the law
so that there's less less window of
vulnerability there agreed thank you I
would like that as
well Senator did you have your hand up
would you like to have it up again thank
you thank you Mr chairman um couple
things one I think the term forensic
hospital was the department ments so
wasn't us telling the department what to
call this place it was the
department telling us what it was and
the key point I think was Hospital
rather than basically cages in the
basement of the Men's prison um
secondly um when the
department proposed a 60 bed Hospital
there was a lot of
concern in the
legislature that it would
just uh well when beds exist they get
filled and there was a lot of concern
that the counties would be
sending difficult patients who they
didn't want to have to deal with and put
them in the state's care and so building
a 24 bed unit was very
intentional on the legislator's part
it's not
like there was a need for 60 beds and we
just said too bad you can't have them we
looked at the population over the years
of the
spu and found that 24 beds was really
reasonable and 60 beds was way too much
and way too much money that we didn't
you thank you Senator I definitely
appreciate those comments and by no
means um in bringing up the 60 beds was
it was it meant to insinuate that we
didn't necessarily get what we asked for
but just to create the clarity around
the forensic component of the population
that will be served and and your
original Point as well uh it probably
was it was before my time actually
significantly before my time I think I
had documentation in my office um
talking about the need for this addition
from like the 1970s um so this has been
in conversation for quite some time and
the term forensic was used back then as
well so um hopefully um we can just
continue to help support and creating
Clarity around the intention of the
space
follow up make one more comment on one
of your slides you refer to it as the
forensic hospital when you talk about
the public outage
so um there seems like the department
still
conflicted about what to call it thank
you for that so I did notice that on the
slide and the reason why I didn't change
the phrase on that particular slide is
cuz that's still the pathway on the
website uh for DHA HS and we haven't yet
updated that pathway to more accurate
language um but but otherwise I think I
I corrected it in the other slides but I
appreciate that feedback that it does
confusion all right um so design review
I'll go through this one quick um so I
mentioned the 24 beds the design as per
the architect company um does allow for
additional beds to be added at a future
State should there be some level of
assessment or determine need at some
point in the in the future um the as I
mentioned design location is adjacent to
New Hampshire hospital that will help
allow for efficiency economies of scale
access to Specialty and access to
Specialty Services that we do currently
provide and of course the design Focus
secure this issue comes up with the
Hamstead and the YDC and so I just want
to make sure that we're we're okay in
this regard between the New Hampshire
hospital and the the new unit uh is is
the um the access between the buildings
is through a an interior secure Corridor
suitable for the movement of people in
the winter and rain and okay yes
entirely accurate it's completely
attached to the Hospital there will be
no need to transition to Outdoors or any
type of risk um for those patients to to
make that transition so so that's
outstanding because that's the way the
YDC needs to be um so uh but it's not
right now but thank
you um so the next couple of slides are
really uh pictures to give you a little
bit more in-depth view of what we're
doing so the site selection you can see
a bird's eyee view of New Hampshire
hospital and where this new build is
occurring and then the next three slides
I believe are pictures of current
progress that I'll walk through with you
and I actually took these pictures uh
primarily from my office on Wednesday of
this week so just two days ago um the
one that you'll see at the end is from
someone else's office a little further
down the line but the first picture you
can see where there's two green
dumpsters in the lower um right hand
corner that is the pad where the
generator will be going and that's work
that they just did more recently you can
see that they really um dug into that
Hillside to create the space for that
generator and um then you can see the
corner of the loading dock again in the
lower right hand side that's the
existing New Hampshire hospital loaded
loading dock but they did uh recently do
that work in that space as well to
create um a little bit more
stability and then sliding if you can
imagine towards the right this is the
current state of construction that we
have right now um this is just one
section of the footprint of this new
build the next picture you'll be able to
see that they are starting digging in um
another location um but this we were
sort of really excited to see because
over the past year or so we've seen a
lot of dirt moving around with with
purpose we're sure but as non-engineers
it's hard to understand until we were
able to see some rebar and concrete come
to fruition so that's been really
exciting and then as I mentioned this
last picture is further to Sliding
further to the right and um them
broadening that footprint of the new
construction and then the remaining
remaining two slides as I mentioned are
renderings that smrt the architect firm
has provided for us this first rendering
is when you drive into the the current
entry point to New Hampshire hospital
you can see the on the left hand side
that is um the existing New Hampshire
hospital and then on the right hand side
where you can see um an outside uh um
space for patient activity that has a
wall and you can see kind of that
mixture of green and tan that is the uh
new construction that's currently being
built yes representative
Weber just reminding you that we have
black and white white slides oh I'm so
sorry of course you do I apologize but
hopefully it made sense still I just
thought it was really
great thank you I'm looking at color
me representative
Edwards okay so we already have talked
about the parking problem and that this
is going to exacerbate it what are you
thinking these days about uh addressing
the employee and visitor parking issues
thank you for that question so the
parking uh well despite the winter
months coming um the parking shouldn't
get much worse than the current state um
so that's a win right um you know
barring significant snow this winter
that that always makes parking
challenging on the campus however I do
um feel good about the support of the
campus broadly and that some folks have
really myself included um taken to
parking further away to get in a few
extra steps so it has manageable um on
any given day depending if there are a
number of remote employees um working
across the campus that's offered relief
of course New Hampshire hospital staff
are not remote but um have been willing
more so that was very nice but you said
that there is no
new there is no new proposal that I'm
aware of to increase parking
representative
Murphy thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my
question it's it's true with was said
before that if you add hospital beds
across the state you're going to fill
them up that just happens it's like a
void almost that just gets filled up so
my question is relative to the 20 versus
the 64 or the 60 versus the 24 beds do
you feel that we are going to be taking
care of our patient the population
you're describing in the state of New
Hampshire throughout the system are we
going to be able to take care of those
patient as
well yes I sincerely hope so um I feel
like uh New Hampshire hospital no matter
how many patients we have and of course
I'm I'm uh unbiased but does a
tremendous job so we they consistently
rise to the challenge in terms of
meeting the need um in terms of overall
capacity I'm not entirely sure yet um I
think we kind of have to see where
things go follow follow up thank you uh
so my my question to go further is only
that and I I I imagine and I believe
that New Hampshire hospital is doing a
great job thank you and I also believe
that you know no matter how many beds we
build they will be filled and you'll be
at capacity before you know it that just
happens so what is the downward pressure
going to be on the counties you know if
if we are not able to house the patient
presentation I'm not sure that's a
question I'm prepared to answer today
okay simple question then is this going
to be the additional um uh units will
that be a vertical or horizontal build
horizontal horizontal okay correct will
that impact parking it already has
impacted parking they've fenced off the
entirety of that yellow outline space
you can't see yellow um but the space um
on that bir eye view of the hospital so
it has it has significantly impacted
parking already thank
you so Senator Rosenwald thank you Mr
chair so representative Edwards and I
both sit on the fisal committee and um
even just last week we approved more
funding for transitional housing as the
backo way out of New Hampshire hospital
so people who don't need Hospital level
care anymore but can't be safely
discharged just right back out to the
community I mean aren't we managing both
the front door and the back
door with all of the arpa funds that we
have committed and moving forward with
this new high security Hospital
thank you for the question Senator and
and um it's an entirely uh great
question yes the answer to that is yes
and thank you for your support in terms
of Housing and funding allocation
because you're entirely correct that
from a systemwide perspective there's
been a tremendous amount of work to
create relief to um transitioning folks
out of the acute care environment back
into community so not just specific to
this unit but of course they work with
mission
you'll hear from kach and Julianne about
the tenure Mental Health Plan update
today um so a tremendous amount of
effort is going into offering some
relief representative Weber and just to
beat the parking issue to death um am I
correct in thinking that some of the
stresses at the moment are because of
the actual
construction and so when the
construction is complete and the fencing
that's required for safety
um and movement of equipment and all the
rest of it is down will the parking be
adequate at that point thank you for the
question I I know that you're that is
correct that there will be some
additional relief offered based on the
uh footprint right now of the
construction there are construction
vehicles there's construction traffic
there's
construction materials um so I do
believe that we'll be able to get
additional parking spaces back once all
of that work is done I'm not I'm not
entirely sure that it will be sufficient
enough especially with the intent of
adding additional staff members to
support this new unit however um we will
be able to obtain some additional spots
you my last slide is just additional
questions thank you for your report
chair our recognizers Henry Lipman for
Medicaid enhancement uh for children and
also good morning again Henry lman for
the record State Medicaid director would
you like to have Sarah come up too sure
okay because I think the first report's
pretty short U I think you have it
electronically from from John Williams I
think I highlighted in green basically
the the change which is we now have one
year worth of um information in terms of
the number of women that were able to
take advantage of the
expanded
um um postpartum coverage from 60 days
to a year and that was
381 um women were able to take advantage
of that um that began October 1 of 2023
we're still in the unwind period um the
tail end of the unwind period so you
know the number could be a little bit
higher in the next year now that we've
got basically a Year's worth of
experience we allow for some claim
runout which is typically we allow six
months to get a you know a more complete
picture next report I'd like to come
back with some you know what what do we
see from metrics that would indicate
that the benefits that were used and I
think it'll take a little longer to look
at the health outcomes component of it
but those are things that we're going to
build upon with each um subsequent
report I take any questions on that
component
the second part of the uh required
reporting is basically what we did to
ensure that um home health benefits
weren't restricted I think in the prior
report uh there's really no change we
made the legislative changes required in
22 um through Rule and uh I
not um from constituent standpoint I've
not received concerns about how that's
working if if you've heard any issues on
that I'd love to hear those um but I
think we've got that issue sort of in
place um and you know um I suppose over
time we could look at try to bring back
some metrics in terms of what the
differen is that's making in the health
of our population but I think that's um
something that we could um build into uh
future
reporting any questions on this for Mr
Lipman or Dr
fny representative Edwards uh thank you
Mr chair uh I'm just um again just
thinking General thoughts and I'm I'm
wondering about the utility of this
report going forward do do you think
we're always going to need this
quarterly report or do you see uh Sunset
I I hate to just keep adding
requirements to the department and never
take any away I'm so glad you asked that
question it was your body language I
could feel it no I I would like to
report to you because on the postpartum
part of it because I think that you what
we were looking to see was that it made
a difference in in outcomes for um you
know the concerns about what happens um
to our population um with uh either
mental health issues you know postart
depression you know um you know part of
the initiative to produce this
legislation I think uh was you know what
we've seen in terms of very unfortunate
circumstances you know I think there
were people who even came to the table
to testify who had family members who
had committed suicide Post delivery we
also know that um cardiovascular
conditions post uh in the postpartum
period are
um something that we have an opportunity
to improve upon um and I think uh
the what I've seen from other states in
Mississippi presented at our last uh
national meeting about um you know the
the importance of the health of the
mother in terms of the outcomes of the
child and I think you know that is
something else that I'd like to be able
to you know produce some metrics on
eventually that you know healthy mother
um those has a better experience in
terms of raising the child which you
know when when that doesn't happen well
a lot of the things that we deal with in
Health and Human Service come into play
right um and so um I think those are
important things to look at given all
that uh what should representative
Edwards put in his LSR in terms of
frequency of report I I think if we did
something that you know at least
annually would be if you want to um
phase into it we could do a a six-month
and then after in a subsequent year go
to annual so that you you're getting
regular information I think when you're
looking at metrics it's a year's time is
typically more valuable but I think you
know just updating you on enrollment um
of postpartum and then you know an
annual report on sort of quality metrics
would be what I'd like to see uh
representative I I'd be happy to do that
I I could use some text to we' be happy
to put together and and then if it's an
annual report we just need to be clear
on when the best time timing of that
would be yeah so we run the Managed Care
Program same thing with the state fiscal
year so I think um something that would
be like six months after the close of
the fiscal year would give us you know a
time to to have mature claims data and a
chance to put something together
representative
Weber
ah see I always ignore her but I'm now
looking this way representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair and Mr liin thank you
for your comment about the quality side
um many times we have things that are on
the quantity um but we always don't hear
about the quality and what I'm more
concerned about from this committee is
how it's impacting patient care um it's
nice to have the numbers but I think
your point on the I want to say I thank
you for bringing it to our attention is
looking also at the Quality side are we
actually doing something with patient
care to improve it so thank you thank
you representative Weber thank you um
following up on representative Edward's
question I'm I'm really comfortable with
that in the dental capacity because it
seems to me that we've rolled out the
plan and you know the question is how is
it working going forward and are there
changes that are going to be needed
um just speaking for myself and I kind
of wonder about other members of the
committee uh the postpartum care is
something that I think I might want to
hear about more often as it's still sort
of newer and again there's there's more
in-depth quality of life issues to look
at there in that I noticed that the
report we have unless there's another
one that I haven't found in the papers
here is all on the dental and the there
isn't anything on the postpartum side
unless I've missed it John John um
Williams sent an electronic version only
one page I'll find it he didn't but I I
don't know how maybe I'm just being too
fussy so I'd love to hear from other
committee members as to whether they saw
a differential between those two things
um I do and I appreciate that and I
think since it took a lot of persuading
amongst some of my colleagues that going
out to a year
is Nob brainer we might want to keep the
data a little bit more frequent until
this becomes the normal in some people's
minds sure we can put together some
language for um representative Edwards
and to we can share with the committee
and so representative Merchant just more
of a comment than is a question I want
us to say thank you to Dr Pinn about
having the dental clinic mobile dental
clinic going to Claremont it was so nice
to see this hopefully it's on it's on
radar and it's going to happen has been
postponed but I want to say thank you
for the work you put behind it well
you're welcome uh that was definitely a
a high priority um I do have um a number
of comments that I'm I'm ready to share
with you when you're finished with uh Mr
lman I think we're finished with the HB
2 chapter 79 report and if one more all
right okay so I'm I'm happy to submit a
housekeeping Bill I'm not looking
to cause any consternation about a fight
over frequency I just raised the
question theoretically you know whether
the report timing is still accurate so I
I I'm totally willing to defer to your
sense of need I I think I think we can
work together on that if the department
might be kind enough Mr Williams to
provide us with some language then you
co sponsor
sure Mr Williams has been volunteered to
provide language thank
discussion and now Medicaid Program
adult Dental Medicaid expansion updates
Andy Lipman and Dr Sarah finny um thank
you very much for your time this morning
um Mr chairman and committee um I have
uh a lot of of good information to share
with you if you turn to um go past the
cover page on the slide deck to the
first slide which is service utilization
and program Administration I'm happy to
say that we are over 16,000 members
served uh since the beginning of the
plan um in April of 23 and that
continues to grow every month uh if you
look at the chart of claims PID and
monthly members scene um you'll see that
there are some seasonal dips but um our
summertime dip this year was actually
less significant than in
2023 we are consistently running between
2700 3400 claims per month and 2200 to
2600 unique members a month being served
which are is very good for the age of
this
benefit um and then before I forget I
want to link back to um the postpartum
uh program that Mr Lipman was talking
about because we do have um a piece in
the the dental benefit pertaining
specifically to pregnant women and that
is that um those individuals do get an
additional cleaning uh that is part of
the benefit during um their pregnancy
and this is to start to address what we
know can be some um um side effects of
poor uh oral health on um both the um
time the the length of the pregnancy and
and early
delivery um so we are not only um
including that as part of the plan but
one of our quality measures is
specifically on what are the results how
is it working so you know obviously
we're in the first year of this quality
improvement project but we're looking at
you know how are the were the mothers
informed how are the providers informed
of this benefit and what support is
given to make sure that the benefit is
being used and um so I I will hopefully
next year be able to share with you what
the results of that are and um so you
know we're definitely trying to look at
quality in this benefit um and I
realized this morning when I was going
over my slides I meant to include a link
to the adult Dental quality page on the
state's um Quality uh website and so I
will email that out to all of you with
the direct link to go directly to the
adult Dental benefit and you'll see that
we
have probably at this point um somewhere
between 30 and 40 different measures and
of course again because this is a young
program we're just now getting to the
point where we have a Year's worth of
experience that we can start to look at
the data and and get some meaningful
information out of that but we're
definitely um you know sticking to the
plan that this should be value based and
that it should be prevention oriented
and so everything that we're doing is
keeping that in mind and trying to
encourage our members to not see this as
an emergency plan like what they had in
the past but this truly is a more
traditional plan where you get your
urgent needs met but then you also
prevention representative Merchant thank
you Mr chair um in regards to the
quality is there in the
metrics a link between oral health and
physical health in other words what I'm
trying to get to is that if people have
um dental care doesn't have a pronounced
impact or any impact on the rest of the
physical care looking at if you will
driving down medical costs because
they've been able to take care of the
dental right and that is is coming in
the future uh but also what we have
provided right from the outset is Extra
Care Management for individuals with
special Health Care needs so that they
are not you know falling to the side um
so that's how we're starting and we are
building the relationship between the
dental organization and the mcos um to
that end because we realize that we need
together yes
sorry
Senator thank you Mr chairman
um can you tell us a little bit about
what how what the utilization Trends are
is it cleanings mostly or is it
restorative or what are people coming in
for and also what are the weight List
look like that's a very good question
thank you for that question and I was
actually going to get to that when I
talked a little bit more about mobile
services but I'll certainly answer that
question now I think that um initially
it was more urgent needs that needed to
be met we've seen a lot of extractions
which which is what we expected but very
interestingly in August Sal Healthcare
came to us and said that they wanted to
add hygiene services in addition to what
was currently offered during the mobile
visits so now we have basically doubled
the number of visits that are available
for each mobile event by adding another
hygienist there because what is
happening a a large number of the
individuals who were treated did
restoratively in the U beginning months
of the program have now started to
transition to needing more preventive
services so this is what you would hope
to
see Sarah com the
weekend representative Merchant thank
you Mr chair one thing that I've um
shared with this committee before is
from the provider side and that's
looking at no shows and you know they're
kind enough to sign up for the program
usually it's not as advantageous
financially as it would be a uh a
commercial payer if you will so are we
tracking or trying to get some feedback
my concern is with the providers that if
we have a lot of no-shows that show up
in this
clientele that they may decide to back
out of the program so are we tracking
that any way to Ure that we're not
getting sort of a yeah um and that's
also a very good question so thank you
for asking that um I have not
gotten an unusual amount of commentary
about missed appointments what we are
doing within the program is uh there are
two codes their procedure codes that are
used to track either missed appointments
or late cancellations and we are
tracking those and part of the reason
besides you know wanting to have that
data is that that information is shared
with the care coordinators who are
reaching out to the specific individuals
who have missed appointments and trying
to speak with them to find out what was
it was it child care was it
Transportation were you sick and to try
to give the support to these individuals
to make sure that when they do make
future appointments that they're there
and if they really can't make the
appointment that they you know do the
Outreach that they need to to change it
so um I I would have to say I think
we're I think it's working because I
have not gotten that as a
a as strong a comment from providers as
in the
past I didn't see this anywhere in the
handout maybe you're going to get to it
in your presentation but I'm interested
in changes total number of unique
providers unique locations unique oral
surgeons unique oral surgeons location
have we pretty well plateaued in those
things because you've got everybody
signed up to do the procedures who sign
up aable or
or all right I if you're finished with
questions on utilization I see
representative Edwards has
representative Edwards is my next slide
okay so Mr Litman if if this isn't a
50-50 match correct me I I think this is
a 50/50 match so individuals who on
granted advantage to be a 9010 match so
there is definitely 9010 money in here
um I don't have it with me but I can CH
that's all right um but it's at least 50
yes okay and and and the general funds
portion is currently being paid for out
of the centine fund are we tracking I'm
sure you are but let me say that
differently I'd be curious to know the
burn rate of the centine money and the
implications that burn rate has on uh
next year's budget we have actually our
last slide deals with that very question
um but I'll take it while you have asked
it is that um we have uh forecasted that
thank you we have forecasted that the um
the settlement money based on the level
of utilization is going to last us
through the next bium um and so we're
not expecting to ask have to ask for an
appropriation and the budget for for
dental for the adult dental program
which is longer you know when we sort of
built the initial budget we didn't have
a sense of what the sign up and the use
rates were going to be we use sort of
national expectations and um and in the
last SL we'll also talk a little about
we protected ourselves from the state
standpoint with a minimum medical loss
ratio um and so we're getting money back
that that was above or excuse me below
what the expected spending was and
that's what's allowing us to to go all
the way out to 27 okay thank you Mr
chair thank you Mr
lman okay so now we can move on to the
next slide which is our Network
dashboard so um to answer your question
representative Pearson we have plateaued
to a certain extent
however um as I noted on this slide
there have been over 350 in-person
office Outreach visits um by a uh
provider relations representative from
DentaQuest that includes office that are
not currently enrolled as well as
circling back with current providers to
see if um if situations have changed
that they're able to see more um members
than they were initially and to try to
provide support to them if they have
issues that may have gone
unmet um so we are actively working on
that and I can tell you that since I
received this dashboard dashboard on the
11 of October I know that there are at
least three more providers coming
through the pipeline that will be
enrolled within the next few weeks um we
have not given up on on recruitment uh
and I think that retention is just as
important which is why this
representative is still going around and
meeting with the offices that are in
network um to have a touch base with
them um you know we are still meeting on
a weekly basis just as we did when we
were going through implementation we
have a standing agenda where items do
not come off of there until those issues
have been completely addressed finalized
we bring new things on every week um I
can tell you that you know DHHS
Northeast Delta and DentaQuest and
salair for that matter are at the desk
every week looking at what's working
what do we need to work on what can we
improve because we know we can't rest
we're not where we need to be entirely
yet so um I think one of the things that
we have been trying to um let providers
know is that some of the classic things
that were less tolerable about being a
Medicaid provider that we have addressed
are coming true um we've tried to refine
credentialing as much as we possibly can
you know the the unfortunate piece is
that because this is a Medicaid Program
they not only have to enroll with a
dental organization but they have to
enroll with the state as well so you
can't get around those two credentialing
um times but claims are processing very
quickly if a clean C clean claim comes
in it pays within a week
generally
um and
sorry okay
um uh um you know claims uh processing
is going well we have minimal procedures
that have to have prior authorization
because that was another sticking point
we have looked at the fee schedule and
changes have been targeted to certain
procedures that we realized there was an
issue with um our reimbursement being a
little too slim and so I I think that if
we can all talk more about the positive
parts of this program and we're we've
really tried to listen to the providers
and the members for that matter um we
have tried to address those things uh to
make the program better than your
Program representative Murphy thank you
Mr chairman um thank you for the report
I'm my question would be you know it may
be obvious that finances it's follow the
money you know type of thing but what is
it in your experience now that uh
incentivizes or disincentivizes a
provider should take on some of these
patients so is it is it no shows is it
you know the type of patient is it the
reimbursement what is it that now
actually one of and this is a very good
question one of the major issues is the
workforce challenges that we have in
dentistry just like every other health
care profession and many of the
providers who have a limited um opening
for for our members to be seen it's
because they don't have enough staff to
increase the number of members they can
see so just follow up follow thank you
um what
percentage what what's the average
percentage of a
provider uh that has these patients on
their um uh profile do you have an idea
of what percentage of a routin provider
takes so for instance in New York City
you know the the goal is not to have
insurance you know if you don't have
insurance you are a star so my question
would be what percentage of the you know
the routine dental office has these Prof
panel commercial insurance or just
Medicaid probably uh and
I am going off of numbers from the
health policy Institute of vaada of how
many many dentists we have in the state
of New Hampshire I would say roughly
25% okay so I think your question may be
what's the payer mix of it so oh the P
um it's sry if you don't have it's
that's really tough for me to answer
because because this is managed care I
don't hold all of the
um claims data and the information about
the
offices and the volume that they're
seeing in our program um but I will take
that question back and see if I can get
appreciate okay if I if I could maybe
provide a little bit more context here
you know um the New Hampshire Medicaid
Program is the fourth smallest in the
country um you know we have um one in
seven citizens are in the program you
know our neighboring states like Maine
and Vermont are typically one in three
one in four maybe one in five at points
in time so in terms of what you would
expect of an overall um pair mix that um
you know I think the insurance
department was just reporting today in
the commercial Market Medicaid
represents about 9% of of the the
business
and yes followup so that generated
another follow-up question for me I
guess then um
if we rank in the fourth or fifth you
know percentile or number of where we
are as far as the Medicaid Program goes
in this country um what what is our
reimbursement rate
rate so so on on the dental side we did
a study with um our actuary on that and
if I'm remembering the number right it's
like 72 or 73% of commercial which is
part of the appropriation that was made
was I think to address that um component
and also so the the last uh legislative
session allowed us to have the rates for
children and adult to be the same so
there's not a disincentive to see adults
and or children and so I think um as
compared to other Medicaid programs I
think we're probably you know in the top
courti now in terms of what Medicaid
you okay um then we can move on to the
upcoming schedule for the mobile clinic
is the next slide um as you can see
these are booked out a month and a half
to two months in advance um going over
the weekends they have added some
Fridays uh you know and again that has
to do with
Staffing um the mobile clinics are are
having I think very good uh results in
terms of no shows uh they are uh you
know confirming appointments and in a
multiple you know number of ways and
they also have weight lists so that if
someone does cancel they have the
opportunity to try to get someone else
in to fill that slot and I think that
their their methods have gotten better
as time has gone on um and as I said
earlier they have recently uh Midway
through September added an additional
hygienist each weekend and that has
virtually doubled the number of
appointment slots that are available um
at each event and so I think that as we
look at our claims and and member
treatment numbers moving forward that's
going to start to show that you're we're
going to see another um rise in both of
those things if somebody wishes to book
an appointment how does he or she do
that uh there is a specific phone number
um and I'm glad that you asked that
question because we have really tried to
um notify our members in a number of
ways how they can make
appointments um there is a flyer that is
posted on the New Hampshire Medicaid
adult Dental web page um there is also
information on the member portion of the
dest portal where they can go online to
den aest and see what the the schedule
is we also push out notifications in the
department social media feeds so if you
watch over you know I think On th either
Wednesday or Thursday day there was a
posting out there for um the visit to
lonia this week and it includes a link
um to those that flyer but also has the
phone number for that I have some
Medicaid people in the medical practice
I oversee and I do not I'm not in the
clinical side so I would not know
whether some of these people would wish
to book an appointment could you tell me
the telephone number please I don't know
it offand but you know what I will do
when I get back to my laptop I will send
the flyer to each of you so that if you
have constituents who need that
information you have the whole flyer
okay representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair and also
thank you for the information about the
mobile clinic um obviously social media
is well utilized one of the things I
would like to do is again the same thing
if we boost that into uh we had
something called what's up Claremont
which is well it's over 14,000 people
follow it I don't want to be doing
something that's going to cause more
heartburn so if I take the information
and post it on the social media or post
it onto the um the city's um newsletter
if you will I don't want to trip over
something all of a sudden have something
causing a problem that would not cause a
problem okay I mean we're really
reaching out to our stakeholders like
the New Hampshire um oral health
Coalition very graciously posts a lot of
this information just for that reason we
want to get the information out there in
a number of places because hopefully you
know every member will at least find one
you all right um and then moving on to
the last slide but I'm going to leave
the final slide for Mr Lipman to talk
about the DLR but um I do want to talk
about um stakeholder engagement and a
and a couple of different things
um as you can see we continue to meet
with um a number of different
organizations and groups because we want
to make sure that we're we're really um
hearing everyone's voice so uh to that
end there is a member event on November
7th at the Manchester Health Department
and also it is available online that is
specifically to provide um information
to our members about what does the
dental benefit provide what does it look
like answer questions for them um and
again that's something that is posted on
our website and that um information has
also gone out and will go out again on
our social media feeds uh and I am happy
to share that flyer with you as well um
for any of your constituents that may
want that
information um and then in addition to
that there is both a provider advisory
Council and a member advisory Council
that dent Quest has these meet quarterly
and with the intention that they have
direct conversations with the two groups
that are most important to the benefit
the providers and the members so that
they can really hear what's going on get
feedback directly from those individuals
and then work on um the information that
they
receive do you want me to
mention that's all right I have two
um very happy uh updates to make number
one is um we recently found out that the
center for digital government uh in
their 2024 digital States survey gave
New Hampshire an A minus grade for
exemplary work in Health and Human
Services um Information Technology
systems specifically calling out the
work that we did with the adult Dental
benefit implementation and um the fact
that we really went from July uh 20122
to April 1st 23 and stood up a benefit
in that amount of time which really
takes a lot of very hard work so I'm
very proud to be part of that team I
want to say thank you um to all of you
for supporting this benefit as well as I
I have to thank everyone at the
department and Northeast Delta and
enquest that worked on this um so that
we could bring the plan forward and then
the second um very hot off the press
information is that um our own as in
conquered z um Dr Richard Rado who is an
oral surgeon here in conquer was just
elected president elect of the Ada on
Tuesday and so he will take over as
president next October he'll spend this
year following the current president and
learning the ropes um rich is a a
wonderful human being has devoted
himself um above and beyond um to oral
health and dentistry and I'm thrilled I
was able to be there um when he was
elected and to celebrate with him uh but
we should all be very proud that one of
our own is going to represent us on the
national
level I asked this question a while ago
and
I just wonder if there's anything new to
share any work on Contracting with
dentists to be or very newly minted
dentists uh loan forgiveness in exchange
for yes we continue to work there's the
state loan repayment program which um in
the past did not allow Private Practice
dentists to tap into those funds there's
a separate program for them so it's not
just dentists who are affiliated with
federally qualified Health Centers and
community health centers so those are
two state run programs um Northeast
Delta Dental has a program their own
student loan repayment program now for
Maine Vermont and New Hampshire they
have already paid out probably close to
$2
million um in the two years that that
has been operating um I also the
department has a recruitment contract
with by state Primary Care Association
they go to dental schools to Career
Fairs uh there's a whole recruitment
piece there going on um so we are we are
definitely looking at all the ways that
we can you know bring these dentists in
and all of those loan repayment programs
have a Medicaid piece to them that you
do have to see a certain um percentage
of of your
um patient mix is from from Medicaid and
the the amount varies from program to
program representative Murphy thank you
Mr chairman and for the record the new
president of the Ada his last name is
you all right representative Edwards
thank you Mr chair I I saw the award the
a minus and I've heard a little bit
about it I I just want to make sure I
understand the uh how the dental program
tied into that digital Excellence award
I am I right to
assume that it wasn't the clinical
aspect or or or of the program it was
the implementation of the eligibility
through the it systems and and if that's
the case was that an mmis
uh adaptation I mean it's a great
program you know I love this program but
I just wanted to understand what the
award was was
for it it was um New Hampshire
doit deserves a lot of credit here in
terms but the way if you kind of think
of it this way that the the the
infrastructure side is New Hampshire
doit so when we're making system changes
to accommodate the the benefit we rely
on New Hampshire doit to do work plus
the vendor um that uh supplies conduit
who supplies the the technology but
there's a lot of work that had to be
done in mmis which is where I think that
the the the recognition is coming from
and and the work that they did you know
it was um U we we were told by CMS was
the second fastest ever benefit that
they ever saw stood up and dental and it
required I think New Hampshire doit to
adjust priorities and and to to work to
recognize how important it was you know
I spent um we spent time at the
beginning um just trying to share what
the consequences of not meeting
deadlines were and um you know the um
commissioner's team from doit were you
couldn't have asked for a better partner
in doing that and I think that uh the
commitment they had to making something
stood up it wouldn't work without them
so very thankful for their
partnership that that's outstanding I
mean the state spends a lot of money on
mmis and on other infrastructure so it's
nice to see sort of U an objective uh
quality achievement so everyone involved
thank you there's also uh work that went
on on the elig I mean the the system
that where we do the El hold the
eligibility the new height system
sometimes um they they deserve credit as
well in terms of um the work that they
did to support standing it up because
they were a key part of the the um cost
sharing uh the co-pays so there were a
lot there was a lot of technical work
this follow up so do I assume at some
point because so many moving parts were
in there there was like a a single
person or maybe two people that were the
project managers that coordinated and
drove all of this if if if there's an
actual human that was the project
manager of all this I would I I mean
because it wasn't just sort of a blob
that moved it had to be somebody who
made it happen right I I'd like to know
I'd like to know who the that individual
is because i' I'd like to do something
to recognize the individual who maybe
spearheaded and coordinated this overall
project
think I you're here his name AI so we
can it's probably fair to say there's
project manager on on the technical side
from New Hampshire doit we can share
share that and then from the Department
side Sarah was obviously um instrumental
but Olivia May who was on the Medicaid
team um and Ken gagy who was on the doit
team would probably be the two like
quarterbacks of making sure that this
happen on time right um You said gag and
La yeah gagy and Lacy um Olivia o i v i
a right May m a y and um Ken gagy g a g
NE um from New Hampshire dyt I'm sure
there are other people but who the one
um Mike U Mike Williams is the other
person from New Hampshire dyt who is was
was Ken's boss I think at the time right
yeah
right
Mr all right and representative Murphy I
would I would just say that before
representative Edwards gets ahead of
himself a bit if we give him time to uh
think of others that may have been
involved um if you could email
representative Edwards with those names
as well so I appreciate it thank
you anyone else from the committee
representative Merchant it's more of a
comment than a question I just want to
say thank you for all the work you put
into this program it's made a tremendous
difference and I wanted to recognize
that thank you thank you very much and I
appreciate all of your support yeah and
you just in closing uh the last slide is
just shows the amount of money that we
expect to recover from the first 14mon
period um you we used about I'm thinking
about 40% of the expected full premium
in the first year um and um
so I'm I think also too a key element
not all states have it was a minimum
spending on medical if they didn't meet
that amount that gets rebated and so
we're forecasting about 6.4 million of
that's coming back to us and if you use
that number um compared to the 24.8
about 25% of this is um coming from the
state share if you will um so the way
these recruitments happen is the feds
get back their portion that they put in
and the state gets back its portion that
we put in and so you can see out of
24.8 um we're expecting
6.44 um and uh 18.4 will go back to the
in thank you thank you wonderful thank
you for all the time and the question
and now the 10e mental health plan
you so good morning Mr chair and members
of the committee I'm Kaa Fox director of
the division for Behavioral Health and
joining me is Julianne kban who is the
Deputy division director and I also want
to recognize that we have with us this
morning two of our Bureau Chiefs um and
they're in training so we didn't put
them on the spot to present the plan
this morning um however it's important
for you to be able to match a name and a
face so I'm going to ask that Daryl
Tenny who is the chief of the bureau of
wave and also our bureau chief for
mental health services Carolyn Lewis who
joined us just earlier this
year
great could we have that last name oh
yeah and so we're really pleased to be
here this morning to present our um key
accomplishments and our 10-year plan uh
report for this year um this is marking
about the halfway mark for our 10e plan
and this is not one of those plans that
sat has sat on a shelf this is something
that has really driven the policy the
programs and the funding requests um
over the last 5 years and as we had in
into the next vium so we started um
getting together saying okay we got to
pull all the information together what
do we have what have we done over the
last year and we're like oh there's not
going to be much to report out and then
we started talking about it and then we
started doing our inventory of looking
at what has been done um over the last
year um as as we mark this
anniversary and so there is a lot that
has happened um so contrary to my first
line of thinking um you'll see that
there has been continued work um and
progress in this Arena and so when I say
we you know we've accomplished a lot I
don't want you to think that I'm
conveying that's the department has done
this this has been done through a
collaborative effort through the
governor the
legislature the all handson um approach
from our stakeholders our Advocates our
uh providers and also most importantly
continue to be informed by the people
that were serving and people with mental
health
conditions and this also reflects some
of the highlights that we'll be going
through um is really looking at um how
we continue to transform our mental
health system to meet today's needs but
also that we're not not just
transforming and constantly in a state
of chaos and change but that we really
need to take time to look at how we're
maturing those programs so what are we
doing to build them out and stabilize
our system um before jumping to the next
new thing so we always are taking that
and balancing those two pieces so that
we're not um again always um changing to
the latest and the newest um but really
looking at the 10year plan as our um
goto and revisiting that um not that
we're not taking advantage of innovation
and new things that come down the line
but making sure that they're aligned and
that we're um we're really investing in
what we already
have um and we've been making use of
one-time funds for infrastructure and I
know that um is really important to the
legislature as especially as you're
looking to this next upcoming um bium um
so to the extent that we could we
invested in uh bricks and mortar um and
then um we also are looking at how are
we maturing those programs um through
such things as mobile crisis in 988 you
probably or you may be aware that some
of the um federal funds that have come
in if you sit on fiscal or pay attention
the governor and Council that we again
are using those funds to build out um
those uh systems so what we want to do
I'll Orient you to what's before you you
have the introductory letter from the
commissioner you have the key
accomplishments around the 12 areas and
then we have some supplemental
information so there's information in
your packet about Mission zero which I
hope that you have heard about there's
is some
data and there is the last piece which
we included uh last year but this is a
little bit more built out around the
strongest Granite
campaign so um what we're going to do
I'll pause there to see if there are any
questions representative
Edwards thank you I it's labeled but I
just want to make sure that this label
is is is accurate this it says
accomplishments in 2024
so Pages 3 through six are an itemized
bullet list of the things that you guys
have done in the last 12 months yes okay
this is just outstanding I I um I'm I'm
really impressed I I I'd like to I'd
like to ask you about something that I
don't see as accomplished in goal one
and and just ask you about it and and
that is um when we when we passed um I
think I think it was uh HB 49 a couple
years ago related to the new Youth
Development Center uh one of the things
about the youth development center uh
was that we recognized that we were
moving to a trauma informed therapeutic
model and that for the length of time
that you would expect a kid to be in the
facility it would be inadequate to deal
with their entire uh setup and treatment
and ongoing care so one of the key
things that were considered conceptually
was that we wanted to actively use the
Youth Development Center as an
opportunity a point of care in the
Continuum to where we would connect out
to the system of care in an active way
using virtual Technologies or or
whatever and so so I'm just curious if
if that's something you've made some
progress on or uh and just didn't list
or if or or what you think about the
status of that and whether it's an
active part of your plan so great Point
uh representative Edwards thank you for
raising that we did give a nod to it but
in a very more vague way than what you
just um described so we could have been
U more clear about that but under the um
intervention intervening earlier so
under goal number three uh the last
bullet does um again give reference to
that under Juvenile Justice
transformation work and really looking
at that um aspect of it so good point um
it may be a revision that's forthcoming
but that is a a part of our ongoing work
through the um work with DCF and
children's system of
care followup I I just want to restate
you know the importance of that
connectivity
um we're spending a whole lot of money
in a new Youth Development Center and
we're doing it on the belief that we
want to make sure that these
shot absolutely and we that connect I'm
sorry I'm just trying to gather myself
it's a personal issue but um just want
to make sure that those kids are
connected to the community so that they
have the best chance sorry that's my
impression so thank you and um I feel it
too I feel it
too I do want to raise um because um of
this critical piece and I just spoke
about this at the governor's commission
about transitions in care and that has
been a significant amount of work that
we have focused on in all aspects of the
work that we are doing uh in the
department so transitions from
residential treatment to community
transitions from a um incarcerated
setting to um lower levels of care and
specifically to what you're speaking of
is that we are now working and um in a
very expedited fashion to work um on a
new opportunity through CMS um which
requires the department to look at how
we are engaging Our Youth and um
preparing them for uh transition to the
community so adjudicated youth at YDC um
um will we're going to be able to have a
a limited Medicaid benefit that provides
targeted case management for those
Services um before they transition into
the community so the whole emphasis is
don't wait until they transition which
we aren't but we're going to be able to
take advantage of that Medicaid um
participation um the federal financial
support to be able to have those
Services um start 30 days prior to um
their um release to the community and
also have it continue on for um another
30 days and so um I'm sure director
Litman would be happy to talk a little
bit more about that but again it speaks
really to what are we doing because we
know how critical um those um services
are going to be for to make that
transition reduce recidivism improve
Community ties improve Family Ties so um
thank you for for raising that
representative
Weber and I guess I would put in the
same plea on behalf of Youth who are
under the care of DCF and coming of age
and who have many of whom not all of
whom but many of whom have ongoing
mental health
needs um and less capacity to manage
those needs than some people do so um I
I I just put in a plug for that side of
things does this grant cover them as
well actually it does it um is not only
for those um who are 18 and under but it
also is for former foster children so
there are um this benefit will also be
part um of the adult uh correctional
system in the
State Prison and in counties and looking
at providing that benefit for them as
well up to age
26 repres Senator Rosenwald thank you Mr
chairman I have a couple of questions if
I could but first I'd like to
congratulate the department for having
Dart meth Hitchcock take over the
management the clinical management of
Hamstead it's not on here but maybe
that's cuz it technically started with
fiscal year
2025 but um congratulations on that I
think that's going to make a big
difference to the population of
hospitalized children um I I sat down
this morning with my first cup of coffee
and ReRe the state's tenure Mental
Health Plan and the first
recommendation was to increase Medicare
provider rates you have it in goal
number
eight um so my question
is we in the budget allocated something
like 304 million dollar of total funds
over the two years for Medicaid rates an
average of
11% across all service lines what was
the actual Medicaid rate increase to the
Community Mental Health
Centers so
um I would invite um our director Litman
to join us if you want to um specifics
[Music]
the question was for the Community
Mental Health Centers specifically what
was their actual Medicaid rating I have
that information I don't have it off the
top of my head um but we do have we've
calculated that um and um you know in
addition to the the rate increase
themselves um for the Community Mental
Health Centers um you know we our
general goal was to Target to be um 100%
of Medicare for the Community Mental
Health centers on our rates um and the
difference of that is kind of what we
sort of measured would be that um and
then I think the other thing is the the
way that we restructured the Managed
Care contract um there is no longer a
maintenance of effort provision in the
between the mcos and the Community
Mental Health Centers and um we are now
requiring that the rates that are paid
to be a directed payment of the the
capitation rate that the actuary
calculate so there's no leakage of of
dollars there so we think that in
addition to what you appropriate as a
legislature that between three and 5
million more based on how we've
restructured the Managed Care contract
will make its way to the um Community
Mental Health Centers but I will get you
the exact numbers thank you could could
I follow up please so we've heard from
the community mental health centers that
they're not allowed to discharge
patients who lose insurance coverage
unlike other doctors who can discharge
pay patients for
non-payment um are we starting to catch
up with redetermining the
still eligible or are we still lagging
and that's affecting
their um Financial
Heth um I think actually today well sort
of simultaneous with this there was a
presentation by the insurance department
what's happening in the market but also
yesterday in health Affairs there was an
article published on kind of what's
happened in terms of you know the
closures and and how many people have
found their way to other insurance um
and I think that um what we've seen is
that it's you know when they lose
Medicaid coverage and become
commercially ensure that that there are
differences in what will be covered
under and that that I think is something
that you know in terms of a goal to work
on with the uh New Hampshire Department
of Insurance and other stakeholders is
you know how do we sort of close that
Gap because I think one of the key
Services is functional
supports um that there's not necessary
alignment in terms of How It's viewed as
being a medical service or not um we
also know that coming up is another um
effort by by um CMS around um looking at
parody of services so I think we have a
ways to go in terms of really getting to
True parody um of what is a covered
service and so I think that's where the
the um mental health centers are are um
having the struggle if you will um and
then we also legislature approved you
know um continuing to um have an annual
update on the the In-N-Out what we're
hoping to see there is that fewer people
um they'll have less bad debt as a
result of moving that um as opposed to
just on an um an ad hoc basis but on a
continual basis moving it with the U
Consumer Price
Index and um I think the the other piece
with respect to the community the
certified community behavioral health
centers that um the funding there and
that model
um there's an enhanced Federal match
that comes with our participation in the
in that demonstration um um for the non
um granted Advantage population because
we're already at 90% but there's a 15 so
rather than getting 50% we'll get 60
um 65% for that population and so I
think that in terms of like Nashville
and Manchester which are the first two
Community Mental Health Centers to to
look at doing this that um some of the
funding that comes through that program
I think will help support um um that uh
care though they have an
obligation beyond what is in sort of our
general um within that demonstration to
accept all that that come into the to
the center um and I I'll let you add to
that getting out of my no um just that
we do work with the Community Mental
Health Centers we do know that the
redeterminations are a factor in that
information um that there may be
individuals who lost coverage who could
be eligible so we continue even um I
think we're meeting in another week or
two with a specific Community Mental
Health Center and we're talking about
how we can keep um either maintain uh
Medicaid coverage or obtain Medicaid
coverage if appropriate and um they're
eligible also um I will point out that
there is a state law that says that
Community Mental Health Centers will
serve might be an administrative rule um
as well um that they will serve all
comers regardless of ability to pay
however in the um budgeting process
since 2011 there's been a provision that
suspends that portion of the law that
allows them to have weight lists um and
um and so that's been their back stop um
it's not preferred but of course it is a
necessity when they're unable to cover
those that are um underinsured or
uninsured so um there is so many efforts
that are going on in this space and um
we continue to work to try to close the
gap and make sure people have coverage
but also that our system um has
sustainable funds and that they're able
to be fiscally um whole
thank you one more follow up I good so I
think we were all disappointed that
solution
Health um was rejected by the town of
London Derry uh for their freestanding
psychiatric
hospital and we turned back those ARA
funds and redistributed them elsewhere
I've spoken to solution health and they
say they are
still planning to build this hospital
they think they're set back for a year
but uh could you update us on what the
department is doing to help them find a
place get that project going so that
we're not sending people who need
inpatient treatment necessarily to the
more restrictive involuntary
commitments that insurance their
insurance coverage doesn't pay
for so um yes um the solution Health um
situation in um the in with the uh Town
Council yes we know about that we had a
deadline for our arpa funding and it has
been redirected and I'm very pleased
that um some of those funds have been
redirected into um housing and so for um
the fiscal Committee Action um which
allows us to be able to use that funding
to provide um transitional housing for
young adults so we know that there are
young adults at New Hampshire hospital
who have could be discharged but they
have no place to go and so through this
transitional housing um we're going to
be able to um have
um not a lot of beds but some beds for
those and that will help for the acute
needs at New Hampshire hospital so that
those um you know I I believe the number
ranges but it's over 50 individuals at
New Hampshire hospital who could be
discharged they just need a place to go
and so this is going to relieve some of
that and some of our other community
efforts um Dartmouth is opening up five
beds drf beds so so that will be an
additional um uh expansion of drf um
beds in a place that needs them um and
so we continue to work on the Community
Based Services as far as the discussions
um with solution health I'm not involved
in those um uh so um that would need to
commissioner I have a question but I
have a lead in to the question to put it
in this context
restoration to competency not just so we
can convict people but so we could
actually bring them to closure and often
we have discovered testimony was given
us that there have been people
incarcerated for a period longer than
what their sentence would be had they
been found guilty with that in mind we
have no intentional restoration of
Competency program in the state if it
happens it's a by chance the um forensic
people are saying it's not our job it's
a mental health issue some mental health
people we talked to maybe not the right
ones are saying it's not us it has to do
with going to court meanwhile nothing is
happening our
committee our committee is charged for
one more
year we would much rather work
collaboratively than impose a place by
legislation other states have this we
don't
we would rather work with the
appropriate folks to do it right and
with a smile on everybody's face than
simply saying if you're not going to
play ball with us we're going to pass a
law I don't want to do that my question
is where in mental health do you see
this
Landing I understand um that there has
been um some robust discussion around
this and um I'm not going to weigh in um
in particular one way or another there
but um I think that it is something that
continues to need uh attention and work
and all the right people um and debate I
think debate is really really important
in this process so that we do get it
right so that's me punting but I think
it again I I I think it's an important
conversation well given my past
relations with the folks in the bureaus
plural I'm sure we'll have a good sit
down and we work hard on it together
because that's been my experience but we
may be giving you call after the first
of the year sounds great thank you
you're welcome thank you any other
questions anything
further no um if there are questions
about I think we could come to the next
meeting in um every single meeting and
uh just spend time on one bullet point
so if there's interest in any one
particular area for us to return be
happy to do so our agenda for next month
looks very very full but guess what
we'll do this again next year after
November's meeting thank you for
coming and with
that motion J well before we get to
motion to a journ um don't throw away
your lawn signs representative Murphy
after a couple of years off uh you'll be
back um I certainly hope so uh
representative Gary Woods gave us this
goodbye soong forever speech and he's
coming back and um I think a couple
other folks are too even my one of my
favorites in the house representative
Shapiro has concluded he's not throwing
away his lawn signs either so we'll see
you in a couple of years if not before
be careful what you wish for is all I
can say so not always we are returned
the date of the next meeting is when the
next meeting is no November 20 22nd
which is not the day after Thanksgiving
November
22nd and look at the agenda just to see
how much ink oh and it goes on to page
two what's that next